[Música]
les doy la bienvenida a ellas hoy mi
nombre es ángela gómez y como cada
semana hablaremos de los derechos de las
mujeres esta vez desde el equipo de
france 24 les traemos un programa
especial para analizar cómo y por qué en
casi dos años de pandemia retrocedemos
cerca de dos décadas en los derechos de
las mujeres y de las niñas la cepal
comisión económica para américa latina y
el caribe y varias agencias de la onu
además de organizaciones activistas
dieron cuenta de la pérdida incalculable
en la lucha por la igualdad veamos
18 años de retroceso ese es el balance
de la cepal tras revisar como afectó la
pandemia a la participación laboral de
la mujer en américa latina y el caribe
por la emergencia sanitaria cambió la
dinámica laboral y educativa de la
presencialidad se pasó al aprendizaje en
línea al teletrabajo y al comercio
electrónico dejando rezagadas a las
personas con menos acceso a lo digital
la lista la encabezan mujeres y niñas
así las cosas por ejemplo las mujeres
entre 15 y 29 años tienen tres veces más
probabilidades de estar fuera del
mercado laboral y de los salones de
clase que los hombres de su misma edad
en el marco del boom en economics fueron
2021 la alta comisionada de la onu para
los derechos humanos michelle bachelet
enfatizó en que la brecha digital ha
estado acompañada de las tareas de
cuidado aún atribuidas a las mujeres
como un destino natural y una carga que
poco comparten los hombres
además son también las mujeres y las
niñas las que han absorbido
mayoritariamente las necesidades de
cuidados creadas por la pandemia
sacrificando sus empleos y su educación
otra dimensión que promovió el retroceso
en los derechos de las mujeres fue el
aislamiento las violencias contra
pequeñas y adultas se intensificó a
nivel global un estudio de onu-mujeres
denunció que casi una de cada dos
mujeres dijo sufrir o conocer a alguien
que sufría abusos desde el inicio de la
pandemia
la agencia de naciones unidas realizó
encuestas en 13 países y concluyó que
cerca del 25 por ciento de las mujeres
se han sentido menos seguras en el lugar
y que los conflictos familiares han
aumentado 21 por ciento denunciar un
maltrato físico de otros miembros de la
familia
las consecuencias del cambio climático
tampoco mermaron en casi dos años de
pandemia y siendo mujeres y niñas una
población transversal a la pobreza a la
vulnerabilidad y a la discriminación
padecieron desproporcionadamente los
efectos de las emergencias por fenómenos
naturales como lo denuncian
constantemente las organizaciones de
lucha por los derechos el kobe 19
empeoró las desigualdades de género y
mostró una vez más que la crisis tiene
rostro de mujer la conversación sobre el
tema es con diana milena samaniego
cerrato investigadora del observatorio
de género y diversidades de la
universidad del rosario en colombia y
con linda cabrera abogada y directora de
la organización misma mujer bienvenidas
y gracias a ambas por estar en ella soy
diana un fenómeno que llama la atención
y que detalló no mujeres es que 24 por
ciento de los miembros de estructuras
nacionales para responder a kobe 19 en
américa latina son mujeres esta falta de
representación refleja la poca prioridad
que tiene la protección de nosotras
sí claro que sí y tiene unos efectos
también muy puntuales uno de estos es
que
no se comprende digamos la magnitud de
las afectaciones que ha tenido la
pandemia en la vida de las mujeres las
niñas y las adolescentes entonces muchas
organizaciones han estado digamos
evidenciando estas afectaciones
particulares pero pues esto no es
suficiente no necesitamos medidas que
atiendan a estas afectaciones pero sobre
todo que transformen los efectos de las
mismas algo que es evidente es que se
han establecido medidas pero de manera
muy general y que cuando se avala la
incorporación del enfoque de género los
gobiernos sólo lo hacen en términos
cuantitativos es decir contar el número
de mujeres beneficiadas por esta serie
de medidas pero lo que no se ve detrás
de esto es realmente la necesidad de
transformar unas y de contener sobre
todo unos efectos que merman la
posibilidad acceso a derechos de las
mujeres
bueno linda y porque es indispensable el
enfoque de género y en esto ha trabajado
mucho sisma mujer porque es vital es
pensar en las transversalidades
angela hola claro que sí nosotros hemos
venido produciendo una serie de
boletines en que hemos identificado
estos efectos desproporcionados de los
que ustedes hablan es sobre las mujeres
y las niñas en la época de covite no es
casualidad estos efectos
desproporcionados porque justamente hay
una situación preexistente de mayor
desigualdad
y una estructura de violencia contra las
mujeres y las niñas que las pone en un
lugar de riesgo frente a cualquier
crisis que en este caso fue el coi pero
puede ser una crisis humanitaria u otra
esto genera unos impactos impactos
desproporcionados como usted los han
explicado en el reportaje y eso amerita
una la respuesta de los gobiernos que
hemos solicitado desde el primer momento
para que se atienda ese impacto
desproporcionado y para que se reverse
esta mayor brecha que se ha venido
abriendo no sólo atendiendo el aquí y
ahora de la crisis de la pandemia para
las mujeres y para las niñas sino los
efectos que a mediano ya largo plazo ya
se están configurado ya se están
consolidando y eso se debe revertir sin
embargo los gobiernos no están adoptando
medidas y pensando en el futuro de las
mujeres y las niñas fíjense que ya
pasaron 2 y no ha pasado nada al
respecto un dato diana que ha resonado
mucho en el último año es lo que
representan las tareas de cuidado si
fueran considerados como un valor
económico sumarían 9% del producto
interno bruto mundial a qué se refiere
esa cifra
pero el pib hace referencia al valor
monetario de producción de bienes y
servicios de un país no entonces cuando
hablamos el 9% del pib a nivel mundial
lo que estamos diciendo es que ese
trabajo de cuidado que es un trabajo
primero que es garantista la
reproducción de la vida es decir el
bienestar la vida misma que generalmente
es hecho por las mujeres que es hecha
más al interior de los hogares que no
suele ser reconocido ni social ni
económicamente
está si lo contabilizamos si le
pusiéramos un valor económico estaría
siendo el 9 por ciento de todo el valor
digamos de toda la producción mundial de
bienes y servicios es decir que hay un
trabajo que es históricamente ha sido
feminizado
qué
digamos permite también no solamente el
sostenimiento de la vida misma de los
individuos sino también de las naciones
de ahí que digamos también hay hace una
insistencia a reconocer como esta
pandemia y sobrecargo a la a los cuerpos
de las mujeres de las niñas
particularmente frente a estas tareas de
cuidado porque nos digamos nos
implicó un retroceso frente a algunas
avances que ya se habían hecho frente a
construir sistemas
nacionales de cuidado a colectivizar un
poco el cuidado a reconocerlo en
términos
económicos pero también sociales pues
porque es algo que sí es muy cierto es
que
las mujeres que han dedicado su vida al
trabajo cuidado no tienen por ejemplo
posibilidad de acceder a un sistema de
seguridad social que les permita a largo
plazo por ejemplo tener una pensión o
acceso a salud sino que esto siempre ha
estado mediada por la dependencia frente
a parejas hijos e hijos oa veces al
estado a través de los sistemas
subsidiados insistimos mucho en el tema
pero parece que no nos escuchan sobre la
importancia de que cuando se protege a
una mujer se están protegiendo todas las
redes que están detrás de esa mujer sus
comunidades sus hijos su pareja sus
padres de todas las personas y toda esa
red de cuidado que existe linda la alta
comisionada para los derechos humanos en
michelle bachelet dijo que para una
mejor recuperación de la crisis los
esfuerzos tienen que tener en cuenta los
derechos humanos de las mujeres y las
niñas porque para eso no hay presupuesto
cuál es el problema de fondo en los
sistemas que están creados para hombres
claro angela lo que pasa es que
en las respuestas que se están dando al
gobierno es una respuesta en efecto
masculinizada por ejemplo en el tema de
la economía cuando hemos tenido en
países como colombia por ejemplo 10
puntos de diferencia en el desempleo que
afecta mayoritariamente a las mujeres
cuando se toman las medidas se piensan
la reactivación de los sectores que como
digo tenían preexistencias de
desigualdad como el sector de la
construcción
y no se piensa en la reactivación
económica también de los sectores que
tienen mayor participación de las
mujeres por ejemplo los servicios
hoteleros los servicios de comercio
informal los atención los digamos
mecanismos en los que está más impulso a
la mujer y que se pueda con eso
facilitar pero la priorización económica
por ejemplo se está haciendo en los
sectores masculinos masculinos y eso
afecta obviamente la leva thyssen
enfatizar las brechas de desigualdad las
que venimos hablando muy bien y ahora a
diana le quiero preguntar en su opinión
cuántas millas se perdieron en derechos
sexuales y reproductivos ya en lo que
vamos de esta pandemia
bueno digamos que el tema de acceso
particularmente a métodos de
planificación fue una gran pérdida acá
en colombia había sucedió algo antes y
era que se había reducido el precio de
the past y de buenos anticonceptivos y
esto creo que era un logro porque
también el tema la capacidad adquisitiva
ya era una limitante para acceder a los
métodos anticonceptivos luego dicen la
pandemia y entonces el problema es que
no podemos salir a comprar estos métodos
anticonceptivos pero bueno se reduce el
ingreso entonces no tenemos con qué
comprarlos otras cosas que nos da miedo
ir a los centros de salud a reclamarlos
cuando nos usa el sistema de salud otra
cosa que sucede también es que las
mujeres seguimos planificando a
escondidas de nuestros familiares
entonces convivir permanentemente con
ellos pues impediría en muchas veces
acceder a estos métodos de planificación
esto por una parte por otra también
estaba el tema de la interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo que
pues aquí
en colombia está reglamentada con la
sentencia c 355 entre tres causales pero
que en este contexto de pandemia
sentiría acceder a ellas no en temas
repito no como acceso a salud entonces
no íbamos a los centros hospitalarios
por el miedo al contagio pero también
digamos que cuando llegábamos allí había
un montón de barreras pues porque la
prioridad era otra no la prioridad era
el cob y entonces la interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo no estaba como
una agenda prioritaria entre la atención
a la salud de urgencias además pero
digamos también todo el movimiento y la
marea verde que se vio en latinoamérica
también tuvo unos efectos justo en este
contexto de pandemia y era bueno la
proliferación un poco de de colectivas
de organizaciones acompañando
digamos los abortos en casa que era una
urgencia pero también vimos lo que
sucedió en argentina luego también
en méxico también en algunos estados
sobre la regulación de la interrupción
voluntaria de embarazo y mientras tanto
eeuu dando pasos hacia atrás muchas
gracias a ustedes no sólo por el
análisis y por pintarnos un poco el
panorama de lo que ha sido la vida de
las mujeres en estos o de casi dos años
de pandemia y pues todavía lo que nos
queda ya para el cierre pues de la
amenaza del virus lo puso de relieve que
esta crisis como las demás en el mundo
tienen un rostro de mujer lo repitió el
secretario general de la onu antonio
guterres y lo han replicado las
organizaciones de derechos humanos usted
qué opina desde casa se comienza
ayudando gracias por estar nuevamente en
ellas hoy y sigan en france 24
[Música]